but those selling dust
okay
in every window you know
they're the others are always
no that's it it's actually an
intersection go this way
specifically engineered work
yeah
so the standing here trying to figure
out where the construction deeds coming
from
don't worry being the hope you had fun
out there conserve my Teigen
pickles
the most recently near we don't like
Oh
we got none right here
same exactly
we normally stop over here so Stanford
medicine catches
well the long discussion no I'm gonna
want to have here
I think we're having issues with shadow
come on let's go keep going I think that
might have been a lane change we go
that's fine whatever doesn't you don't
get beauty in style points Wow I see
dude my comment was Nick thanks Nick for
your support coming up the road where
I'm standing over the top of the road
right there comes coming right by me
yeah lr3 don't nail our fries going
right past me jumping standing aloof I'm
at the rotaries mom
yep I think you should I think I think
we're gettin gettin gettin trash
John I have a visual is at the top yup
he's at the top of a visual yep
still stalking until recently burglar
record vehicles up attend interesting